thomas bonjour le rassemblement a donc
débuté à 14h on le voit du monde autour
de vous quelle est l'atmosphère sur
place mais écoutez le cortège est parti
il ya environ une heure de la place de
la république et on arrive déjà sur la
place de la bastille il faut dire qu'ils
viennent assez courte distance entre les
deux beaucoup de monde des milliers de
personnes c'est assez difficile
d'estimer précisément combien mais
vraiment une forte affluence pour cette
manifestation il ya évidemment des
journalistes qui conteste depuis un
moment cette article 24 de la loi
sécurité globale mais ce n'est pas les
seuls à avoir fait le déplacement
jusqu'à l'heure il ya eu une prise de
parole de la part de certains
représentants d'associations
d'organisations syndicales ou
d'organisations politiques je propose
d'écouter dominique pradalié du snj et
adrien cnas de la france insoumise
c'était au micro de bâtisses gosselin si
cette loi devait passer il n'y a plus un
manifestant qui peut manifester dans la
rue un clairement clairement puisqu'il
ya des drones puisqu'il y a puisqu'il y
aurait des drones puisqu'il y aurait des
caméras piétonne etc
ça veut dire que tout le monde aurait le
droit de filmer côté police et les
salles qui devrait pas loin ce serait
les journalistes extraordinaire alors
est-ce que les télévisions diffusaient
des images de police à la place des
reportages la question est posée que je
pense que cette semaine tout le monde a
vu qu'on avait basculé dans autre chose
entre le vote de la loi sécurité globale
à l'assemblée mardi en première lecture
les événements qui se sont déroulés
lundi place de la république on a vu le
traitement réservé aux réfugiés aux
associations qui les accompagnaient qui
est abject et les images de l'agression
barbare raciste de michel le producteur
de musique c'est étonnamment la semaine
où on vote cette loi on vérifie à quel
point on a besoin de ces images parce
que ces images elles permettre un
contrôle citoyen qui est nécessaire vous
l'avez entendu la diffusion des images
cette semaine de cet homme qui a été
violentée par les forces de l'ordre ont
évidemment beaucoup choqué c'est ce qui
explique aussi en partie la forte
affluence ici dans cette manifestation
il ya aussi des gilet jaune au sein de
ce cortège on le sait ça fait maintenant
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
deux ans approximativement qu'il dénonce
les violences policières dont ils sont
parfois les victimes lors des
manifestations n'a pu croiser faouzi
lellouche une des figures du mouvement
c'est au micro de bâtisses gosselin
gamme on a le sentiment que depuis deux
ans ben les oreilles étaient bouchés et
la parole du gouvernement était muette
il refusait de reconnaître les violences
policières
aujourd'hui alors éclater au visage
c'est au grand jour je me demande
comment aujourd'hui le président de la
république où ce gouvernement il peut
nier les violences qu'il a pu y avoir
avant dans les banlieues et depuis deux
ans dans la rue parce que on contestait
simplement notre droit c'est à dire
contre cette politique est de vouloir
vivre décemment et vouloir vivre mieux
voilà pendant que vous écoutez ses
interviews nous sommes quasiment arrivée
place de la bastille vous le voyez les
forces de l'ordre sont déployées en
nombre notamment sur les flancs de ce
cortège qui continuent d'arriver donc à
la place de la bastille encore beaucoup
de monde qui est encore place de la
république c'est dire l'étendue de cette
manifestation qui on le rappelle avait
d'abord été interdite il s'agissait
d'abord d'un rassemblement place de la
bastille et qui a finalement été
autorisé et c'est donc place de la
bastille que va s'achever cette
manifestation aujourd'hui ici à paris
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions vous retrouve bien
évidemment tout au long de nos
prochaines éditions thomas bonnet en
direct de la place de la bastille à
paris